the conclusion I've come to is identity
politics is a gateway drug to actual
racism so now there were three plus
years into this do you think the damage
has been done regardless and at a
certain level that even if somehow
Briggs it is pulled off and it limps out
yeah that the the faith in the system
will have been so beat and I from my
friends that are British most of them
actually were Pro brexit and they are so
deeply depressed about how this whole
situation has been dealt with that it
almost seems to me that no matter what
happens now that is going to be very
hard to reset I think that's absolutely
a key question which is whether they've
already gone too far you know I kind of
I flit from day to day about weather
breaks it will happen on that but then I
also think precisely that even if it
does happen now have we gone too far
down the route of anti democracy because
what it's it's extraordinary and and to
a lot of American people and other non
British people will be difficult to
comprehend just how extraordinary it's
been but for more than three years the
majority of people in the UK the
majority of voters have been subjected
to relentless daily abuse we've been
told we are ignorant we are stupid we
are racist we are xenophobic we are
driven by a hatred of foreigners we are
driven by a hatred of immigration we've
been told basically that we're scum and
then the way you have your your police
departments in London tweeting out that
we should be watching people for hate
speech that's right other thing that's
right so that at the exact same time
there is this constant policing of what
we say in how we express ourselves and
so there are millions and millions of
people in the UK who just feel
completely beaten down and abused and
treated like crap to be frank by the
political class by the political elites
and they've had enough of it but the
question arises of how they respond to
them will they respond to that by saying
we give up or will they respond to that
we're gonna fight back and that's the
key question off the moment in the UK
and I think across the Western world in
fact and Nigel Farage that I interviewed
Nigel fraud on my podcast a few months
ago and he made the point that the the
two choices facing the British
population at the moment is anarchy or
apathy do you respond to this non-stop
abuse from the woke elites by being
anarchist and saying well screw you
we're going to keep fighting for this
thing that we want or do you respond to
it by being apathetic and saying you win
we give up and I see that dilemma that
choice repeated in fact across the
Western world which is do ordinary
people respond to the relentless
harassment of them by the political
class and the media class and the woe
class do they respond to that by saying
well no we don't accept this and we're
going to keep pushing it back against
your eccentric crazy political worldview
or do they respond to it by saying we're
going to slink off into our own lives
and give up on politics entirely that I
think is the crossroads that the West is
that yeah that seems to be it for
everybody yeah whether you're dealing
with brags it or even what's going on
here which are you going to get engaged
and where does that lead you and how
crazy will you have made those people in
a certain way if you've treated them so
deplorably yes sometimes so obviously I
wanted to bring up Faraj in this I've
met him a few times we had we had lunch
in London I found him to be exactly the
way he is publicly which is boisterous
and passionate and all of those things
and and you know sort of endlessly
overjoyed and but yet he's dealing with
all sorts of nonsense all I sense from
him though really sort about the
political level was that he wants his
people to be free no it's really all I
got from him do you think there is more
to it than that or do you think that
that is enough and you know he he'd won
the other election just in the last -
yes where does this sort of place him so
Nigel Farraj that his most recent
outlet is the brexit party so he has set
up a new political party called the
brexit party and they won the European
Union elections I mean this is how
outraged it was where they were formed
three weeks before a few weeks before
and they won they got more than five
million votes they beat the Conservative
Party they be the Labour Party they beat
the Liberal Democrat Party which are the
three main parties in the UK be all of
them and they won and they are now the
largest political party in the European
Parliament from across the whole of
Europe they are the largest party that
is that is how strong the sentiment is
in the UK for brexit people are still
voting for breaks it again and again in
every opportunity they get so Nigel has
set up this party I think it's a very
admirable exercise I think he is someone
who genuinely wants the UK to leave the
European Union and in fact he has
devoted his working life to that for the
past twenty twenty-five years he was
originally a leader of the UK
Independence Party and now he's a leader
of the brexit party but all along the
way he has been arguing that we have to
leave the European Union because it is
anti-democratic and illiberal and a
really foul institution and he's
absolutely right
he organized a huge rally outside
Parliament a few months ago called the
leave means leave rally ie leaving the
European really should mean leaving the
European Union which I was one of the
speakers at that so I got to meet him
got to speak to him and I much got the
impression firstly that he is someone
who is genuinely committed to recovering
Britain's national sovereignty and
Britain's popular democracy against this
kind of encroaching oligarchical
institution in Brussels and it also got
a sense from the vast crowds who were
there the thousands of people many of
whom came up to me afterwards to talk to
me about what I had said got a very
clear sense that there are huge numbers
of ordinary people who want the same
thing who want us to leave the European
Union who want Britain to go back to go
back to being an independent nation it
wasn't just a big party for racists no
who aid immigrants and hate gay people
and the rest of it it's so infuriating I
think you know the thing that I think if
you
to me most about contemporary politics
is the way in which people are so are so
casually written off it's a new way of
saying you're scum so we don't have to
deal with you but instead of saying
you're scum which would be unpitying
itself
they say you're racist you're xenophobic
you're Islamophobic you're transphobic
you're all these phrases that they've
invented simply to demonize certain
points of view and that's been used
against brexit voters who are all
written off as xenophobic it's been used
against numerous sections of society who
simply want to defend liberal values or
traditional values or conservative
values or any view of life that runs
counter to the politically correct elite
anyone who does that instantly runs the
risk of being denounced as phobic in
some way and that's such a dangerous
approach how would you connect this to
what's going on more broadly with labor
in general so you mentioned that 90% of
them yeah don't want to leave her right
there 90% of them don't want yes which
is against the will of the people that's
one thing but now there's all this giant
you know anti somatic scam yeah korban
which now is starting I think we're
seeing the seeds of it here with the
Democrats yeah I think this new won't
class of Democrats they're teasing out
the very things and I see this from a
lot of conservative British pundits
they'll say yeah that's the type of talk
that we started hearing about six seven
years ago and now it seems like it's
taken over labour entirely
I completely agree I think absolutely
you're absolutely right to draw that
connection between the kind of prejudice
that is growing up in the Labour Party
in the UK under Jeremy Corbyn who is
this kind of supposedly radical Marxist
leader and the kind of prejudices that
you will see and expressed among you
know the kind of radical wing of the
Democrat Party which is this
increasingly anti-semitic worldview and
the conclusion I've come to is that
identity politics is a gateway drug to
actual racism because what identity
politics does I mean it does so many bad
things
it rehabilitates racial thinking it
divides everyone according to their
biological origins rather than a
question of their character and who they
are and what they believe so it's a very
regressive form of politics but I think
the worst thing that it does is the way
organizes every ethnic group and social
group according to whether they're
privileged or oppressed and it has this
obsessive desire to locate every single
group in this kind of hierarchy of
victimhood and what that does it's meant
to generate sympathy for the most
oppressed groups which apparently
includes I don't know in America it
would include African Americans and
Muslims and so on it's meant to generate
sympathy for them but what it does by
extension is generate hatred and bile
for supposedly privileged groups white
men straight men sis people I don't use
the word sis but they do use the word
says and choose because what this these
racist identitarian 's have done they
have decided in their infinite wisdom
that the idea that the jews of victims
is over egged and exaggerated and not
really accurate anymore and in fact we
have to relocate the jews away from this
good group ie victims into this bad
group ie
privileged people and as a consequence
of that a lot of the bile that these
people throw out the racist vile I would
say is targeted at not only white men
insist people and so on but also at
Jewish people so I think actually the
contemporary anti-semitism is not a
product of the the politics of racial
superiority as it was in the 1930s and
the 1940s it's a product of the politics
of identity it's a product of work
politics which has this kind of myopic
urge to divide all these groups
according to whether they are deserving
of our sympathy or deserving of our
hatred it's so interesting this idea
that if you supposedly care
about this group that you've you lower
that it's lower in the hierarchy that it
can't just be about that it has to then
just the way human nature is yes has to
be about hating some guys exactly right
and what it mostly ends up doing I would
argue is it's probably eighty percent
focused on the hatred of yes whatever
that group might be and twenty percent
yeah ends up being left on these people
usually with the wrong solutions
absolutely all right I mean we see this
now in America you know whatever all
these things and with Harvard and they
didn't want a certain amount of Asian
people there so they start having quotas
and we're literally punishing Asian
people for working hard and focusing on
family and education no one came Asian
people anything when they came here to
yank no one gave Irish people are
Italian people yeah which people already
what anything you get here in your ear
yeah look I think that's absolutely
right and I if anything I think it might
even be more than eighty percent as
their focus of hatred
you're being very balanced there but I
think that's right it's it's you know
everyone loses out as a consequence of
the hierarchy of victimhood obviously
the privileged groups the supposedly
privileged groups lose out because they
are the subjects of hatred it's
acceptable to hate them in fact it's
it's socially responsible to hate them
it's socially responsible to hate white
men is it crazy when you hear so many
people what I see and the Twitter
version of this is that what's coming
soon enough within ten years will
actually be laws against these people
that will punish these people yeah and I
think if I would have heard that three
years ago it would have sounded crazy
now it's starting to sound kind of right
that if you if really the ideas of Labor
and what's being born out of our
Democrats coming now it won't just be
about oh we want everybody to have you
know take from some and give to others
just for tax purposes but it'll be about
more proactive ways yeah to punish
certain people and now you know we're
talking about reparations now and a
whole slew of other things I think
that's already happening in some ways
where you have a situation where you
know on campuses on universities and in
other areas of life you have affirmative
action and other measures you know many
of which started out with good
intentions which are now being used to
elevate certain social groups and to
demean or
or handicapped other social groups I
think we're already seeing the origins
of that I think it will go further and
further you know one of my big problems
with this culture of hatred towards
certain privileged groups is that it's
so anti intellectual it's so wrong you
know so for example white men is it's
absolutely acceptable and in fact
cherished to hate white men and you
think so well hold on white men includes
very poor people hard-working people the
the man who cleans your toilet the man
who fixes things in your house when they
go wrong it includes fire fighters who
will save your life you ungrateful
idiots if anything bad happens it
includes soldiers includes all these
people and then it includes incredibly
wealthy people incredibly you know the
minority people who run businesses
people who are bosses and so on so what
the politics of identity does I think
one of the key things it does it
completely erases the question of class
it completely erases the question of who
has things and who doesn't have things
and as someone who comes from the left
traditionally I find that really
worrying where a whole swathe of people
is just categorized as bad on the basis
of the color of their skin with no
discussion about the divisions within
that group of people in terms of class
in terms of influence in terms of work
and everything else so to me it's just
as bad as when I was growing up and
people would do the same in relation to
black people they would say all black
people are questionable by the basis
that they have a certain skin color that
was wrong and that was wicked that was
an evil approach to life because it
didn't take into consideration the fact
that there are vastly different kinds of
black people the majority of them are
good hard-working decent people and if
some are committing crimes it tends to
be a minority it tends to be a specific
problem so it was racist to suggest that
all black people were a problem i
similarly think it's racist to say it's
racially charged to suggest that white
men are a bad thing it doesn't take into
consideration the fact that there are
vast moral
class political differences in this
swath of people so since this woke
monster that's what I always call it
it's a buzzer it's sort of an amorphis
monster that you can't quite shape or
fully understand because it's always
changing and changing the rules and all
those things but because it doesn't seem
to really be going anywhere let's say do
you think that that the populist
movements that are now rising up all
over Europe are the only way to get out
of this and are you worried about that
where that could potentially lead
because I think this is a little bit
where every time you talk about populism
you start talking about nationalism yeah
I think you know people think you're
talking about F no national and there's
this weird sliding scale so maybe if you
could kind of break down yeah view those
differently
well I'm very Pro populist I'm very anti
ethno-nationalism and I don't think
there's a contradiction between those
two things at all okay so can you just
lay those out yeah so I think populism
is an incredibly positive moment now
that doesn't mean that all the populist
movements around the world are good some
of them are good some of them are very
questionable some of them have bad ideas
but I do think all of them in the round
represent a rebellion against the
technocratic politically correct elites
that have risen up over the past 30
years and we can see this with the vote
for bracelet the vote for breaks it was
a very clear statement of opposition to
the bureaucratic elites that run the
United Kingdom we can see it with the
Julie Jones in France who have been
protesting on the streets every single
week for about 30 weeks now I mean for a
long period of time they get virtually
no media coverage you certainly was hear
that answer you right you don't see
anything about brexit you won't see on
CNN but you we don't even get coverage
of the Geonosians on the BBC and we live
right next door to France
we live twenty six miles from France it
is our closest friend me and we we don't
get the coverage of what's happening
that's absolutely extraordinary but I
think with the solutions that's very
clearly a protest against Emmanuel
macron the president of France who is a
elitist paternalistic bureaucratic
politician and we can see across Europe
there are various left-wing and
right-wing populist movements emerging
pushing aside the kind of
social-democratic or right-wing parties
and saying we need a new kind of
politics I think you can also see in the
in the u.s. with the Trump phenomenon
now I don't think the Trump phenomenon
is uncomplicated I think it's very
complicated I think there are many
problems with Trump as an individual and
as a politician and in terms of what he
says and what he does but I think the
vote for him through the electoral
college everyone will say he didn't win
the popular vote we know this but
through the electoral college the fact
that he won is incredibly significant
and I think it represented a rebellion
particularly among working-class voters
where they were saying we've had enough
of the establishment we've had enough of
the establishment politics woke politics
the kind of thing that Hillary and
others were pushing the problem in the
US as far as I can see I think the
Democrats have gone completely nuts
because what they have done is they are
going further and further down the root
off the kind of politics that the people
have rejected so let me pause here for a
sec so since we're saying that we should
view what's going on with labor now in
the UK as a sort of precursor to what's
happening with the Democrats yeah people
always ask me this well is there any
sign that it's going to stop and I
cannot find a sign that at any moment
over these last couple years where the
left went bananas and identity politics
and all of these things and Trump became
president as if that wasn't a big enough
sign I've never seen a moment where the
self-reflection kicked in no was there
any moment in in Labour's dissent that
you saw like a moment where suddenly
there was a chance I mean even if it
didn't actually materialize but a chance
where you go now now they could kind of
recalibrate us or get back to something
because yeah we see you know they throw
and Biden basically is the last chance
yeah he was like take this old guy who
now he's gonna try to play your woke
game - yeah but but he's the last thing
we got that's the great tragedy of Biden
I think he keeps getting attacked by
these woke politicians and he keeps
giving in too much to them
you think stand up for yourself Joe do
you know anyone even like him that much
but man if exactly they end up to them I
would be all about he could clean up and
but you know in the UK that's a really
good question because I think there were
a few moments where Labour thought to
itself where are we going and in fact
there are still sections of the Labour
Party as small sections who are saying
we've gone too far we've gone too far
down the Metropolitan elitist a kind of
woke political route and we need to
recover what we were traditionally about
which was about being a democratic party
a battery a patriotic party a
Nationalist Party it sort of gets us
back to where we started at this
interview actually because I was asking
you can just stay in something and fix
it from the inside or somehow yeah my
view and I've said this to Labour
supporting friends of mine my view is
that Labour it cannot be fixed it's lost
because this has been a long time coming
in fact and I think it's been a long
time coming from the left across the
Western world and and they've made the
wrong decision again and again and again
and they've gone so far down the root of
this kind of elitist distant
paternalistic politics but I think it'll
be very hard for them to come back from
that so the point I make to labour
supporting friends of mine who are still
Pro brexit pro-democracy who think
ordinary people are decent and sensible
rather than idiots I always say to them
you've just got to leave you've got to
set up your own organisation we've got
to do your own thing because there's a
lost cause but I think looking at the
u.s. I'm I'm just amazed at the mistakes
that the Democratic Party are making and
I just think they are making all the
same mistakes of the British left have
made they're going you know this is why
I have this soft spot for Bernie Sanders
not in the sense of economics I think
his economic program is like oh no
that's really not good but there's a
really interesting tension between the
traditional leftism of Bernie Sanders
which tends to be pretty much
class-based and the woek leftism of the
new Democrats and the new left and you
can see it when they keep firing back at
Bernie saying well you're an old white
man you know we don't need another old
white man we need a young black woman
who apparently is superior by dint of
her racial origin right would you say
that's Karma
because I've been saying it it has come
years like they are good not that
they're just gonna pass on him and all
the polls are showing that now he's lost
all his mojo yeah it's not just that
because he's yesterday's news he needs a
straight white man it's that they're
gonna have to destroy him yes absolutely
they have to vengefully destroy him yeah
and watching that happen is going to be
well it gets to what we talked about
before about it's not about saving the
20% how do you help them and that's
right destroy the EFA and they're gonna
have to do it and it's gonna in a weird
way I'm gonna sort of enjoy them doing
it as you know you mean like I don't
inherently that's not how I am
yeah but it's like you sort of created
this thing I get it yeah like the fully
woke thing but you're kind are and now
congratulations it's like them calling
Pelosi racist well I completely agree I
think when politicians like Sanders and
Pelosi and others give in too much to
the work agenda they sign their own
death warrant I think that's a very
clear case of what's happened with
Bernie Sanders in particular you know I
think back to that turning point in fact
when he was accosted by black lives
matters activists and he invited them
onto stage and they write and what he
should have said is no shut the hell up
I'm talking you can ask questions at the
end and he would have got so much
support among ordinary people if he had
taken that that approach to these
arrogant people who thought that by dint
of their origins and their beliefs that
they had the right to to Swan on to any
stage and express themselves I think he
would have won so much public support if
he'd stood up to that but again and
again that's one example again and again
he has given in too much to the woke
agenda so he's kind of signed his own
Warren in many ways but I do think that
if he were to break away if he were to
say I don't care about your skin color
don't care about your sex don't care
about your gender don't care about your
sexuality I care about what you believe
I care about where you stand on
political questions and economic
questions and that's all that I'm going
to judge you by I think he'd win a lot
of support and in some ways that's
what's wrong because idea the sort of
too late for him it's still yes I think
it could be - I think if he had done
that he would have won a lot of support
but he may
the wrong judgments on so many different
so basically that there was a moment
maybe that wasn't my mode before it went
completely bananas where it's at now but
you know I always find it fascinating
that Trump has always been quite
sympathetic to Bernie Sanders and
Hillary Kramer I think actually
bizarrely they have something in common
which is a desire to rise above the kind
of [ __ ] woke crappy PC politics and
to speak directly to ordinary people and
say well what is really concerning you
what are the real issues in your life
let's talk about those Trump has done
that more successfully than Bernie
Sanders I say this is someone who is not
Pro Trump but he has done it more
successfully because Bernie has given in
too much to the other distracting
authoritarian PC agendas but there is a
there was I shouldn't say there is there
was a commonality between these two men
which was how can we go above this bad
politics which has taken the Western
world by grip and talk to ordinary
people about what's concerning them and
their everyday lives both of those had
that instinct I think Bernie has
jettisoned that instinct and has gone
too far down the workgroup so I think
your apps if you people want to take
kind of karma retribution in the fact
that he's gonna be destroyed I think
that's fine because he made bad choices
yeah it's just crappy it's yes it just
is but okay so let's link this back to
to the populism that you're talking
about so I understand that and then what
what is either the connection or the
disconnection between that and then
nationalism and what then veers into
what we should all be worried about
which is actually ethno-nationalism yes
so I think a national populism is a
pretty good thing because I think the
only way democracy can work in a real
way like dude I mean meaningful
democracy where everyone regardless of
their station in society regardless of
how much money they have
regardless how much how much education
they have everyone has the right to an
equal say in how societies organized I
think that's an incredibly important
political value I think in many ways
it's the keeper
core value the only way that value can
be upheld is if you have a coherent
nation a nation which is not interfered
with too much by outside forces which is
not bossed around by a foreign oligarchy
like the European Union which by the way
can write laws that US British people
must live by even though we have no
direct mechanism for pushing aside the
people who write those laws so it's
fundamentally not one outsource all your
freedom right for people in Brussels
amazing right so we don't want to
outsource our freedom we don't want to
outsource our democratic decision-making
processes but that's what has happened
so I see national populism as an attempt
to recover the ideal of democracy and
and borders are actually central to the
idea of democracy because if a nation
doesn't control its own borders then it
really isn't a nation at all and if it
isn't a nation at all then it cannot
have democracy which can only really in
any meaningful sense take place within a
nation humanity has not thought of any
other way that democracy can work other
than in a nation so when you somehow
people sort of think that borders are
are somehow against freedom yeah but
actually they're the only things that
ensure free absolutely and I think the
right of a nation to police its borders
into controllers borders this is
essential now as it happens I'm very
liberal on the question of immigration I
would like a liberal policy on
immigration in the UK and everywhere
else but I think it's the onus is on me
to argue for that in the democratic
sphere rather than having a situation
where in Europe for example the European
Union determines how many migrants
people country should take so that's
implicitly anti-democratic or over here
in the US you have a situation where you
have these kind of supposedly radical
eccentric Democrats who just think
everyone should be able to come to the
US regardless of whether they come
through the legal port of entry
regardless of whether they've tried to
do it in the in the reasonable way they
should think that people should be able
to swarm into the country and and and do
as they please what these two things
have in common is an hostility towards
the idea of borders but it's in hot
hostility towards the idea of borders
that's not based on freedom but it is
based on the idea that the nation is a
is a bad thing and and that democracy is
a bad thing and that we should just
throw everything open and allow other
people to decide the fate of the country
fundamentally anti-democratic you you
I'm sure you're familiar with your
Omaha's Oni and the virtue of
nationalism yes yeah so that that
basically I think you just summed up his
book right quite eloquently there though
that we need these things to protect
freedom so what's the part then that we
have to watch out for as these movements
rights ethno-nationalism is a repugnant
idea it's it's absolutely a disgusting
idea and I say that as you know I live
in the United Kingdom but I'm not
originally a British person my parents
were Irish they came to the UK I'm the
I'm a first generation British person so
you know all these people who say go
back home you don't belong here you've
only been here for a few years I mean
that applies to me right I've only my
family has only been in the UK for forty
five years or so in terms of when my
parents came over so we're very new
arrivals the idea of ethno-nationalism
would expel us instantly and it would
expel so many of the people I grew up
with black people
Asian people Indian people Chinese
people all these people that grew up
with who I know for a fact felt a real
sense of attachment to the United
Kingdom as a nation as a political
project as a democracy so the ugly thing
about ethno-nationalism is that it
determined citizenship on the basis of
race on the basis of skin color on the
basis of the native istic idea of where
your family comes from the great live
Ed's are the same coin that sounds a lot
awful lot like that identity part
exactly and this is the great that is
such key point because the great irony
of contemporary politics is the kinship
between these horrendous
ethno-nationalism won by skin color and
these horrendous identitarian who did
the exact same thing and and what both
sides share in common is this racial
obsessiveness this hyper racial
awareness
where everyone has to be judged
according to their pigmentation or other
kind of biologically inherited trades
whereas I think the the really
progressive thing to do and I know
progressive means something differently
us than it does in Europe but the really
decent thing to do the really decent
thing to do is to judge people not by
their skin color but by their character
I mean that famous someone said it but
you know holding on to that idea is so
important right now
character is what counts belief is what
counts your willingness to commit to the
nation and to your community that's what
counts it doesn't matter what color you
are doesn't matter what sex you are
doesn't matter who you sleep with it's
the question of who you are as an
individual and I think that is an
incredibly positive idea and it's under
attack from both sides it's under attack
from the supposedly all right which I
know is an overused phrase but the ethno
nationalist and it's under attack from
the left identitarian and I think
defending that idea that you can be part
of a nation regardless of where you
originally come from is so important we
have our work cut out for us
which is why unfortunately I'm gonna let
you go now but we will do this again
soon it was definitely sooner than two
years but yes a lot more we can be doing
here brendan is wise enough not to be on
Twitter but you can follow spiked online
at at spiked online and don't forget to
click the subscribe button right here on
YouTube and make sure to turn on
notifications so that you can actually
see our videos in your feed how novel I
know it's crazy isn't it
you
[Music]